joining us now is an american
he's trapped in afghanistan desperately
trying to get out
we have decided not to show his face not
to name him because his life would then
be in serious risk at this point if his
identity is exposed to the taliban he
now joins us sir thank you for being
with us can you tell us what is going on
now and what you see unfolding
good
know just you guys evening know that i
started here with my family
uh
we had the tickets it was cancelled
before the taliban you know get the
control
all around here uh and finally we tried
to
get contact with it
this was just a previous power response
finally i got definitely an email
um
come to the case which is you know
get by the military just to get out
from afghanistan back home
so we've tried to go there with the
family
well unfortunately we couldn't make it
because
when we're in here we see thousands and
thousands of people fighting
we try to get closer but unfortunately
we got fast with the taliban and they
just come in front of us and put the
camera on my chest
and said this
get out of kenya rather than even trying
to fight
it
i'm really scared you know i
was really frustrated and wondering
uh finally
inside
because thousand and thousand people was
on the line
and
uh i see there was no way
to get there because of too much rush
i made it finally safe back home and
waiting for what to do
and how to get out of here
to make it back home
sir it's uh we have a little bit hard
time hearing you but i've been able to
pick up an awful lot um
our thoughts and prayers are with you
may get home safely may god guide you
home safely we're praying for you and
your family and every other
person behind enemy lines tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else